venezuela's embattled and disputed
president is once again blaming the US
for his country's economic and political
crisis Nicolas Maduro says the Trump
administration is responsible for his
many troubles State Department
correspondent rich Edson has details
Venezuela streets filled with familiar
traffic another day of protesters
demanding disputed president Nicolas
Maduro leave for el cielo Boris
in an interview with the BBC Maduro says
Venezuelan voters have given him a
mandate to lead and claims the United
States is trying to create a
humanitarian crisis to justify an
invasion beautiful crypts that I believe
that the extremist sectors of the white
supremacist of the Ku Klux Klan lead the
United States I believe it's a gang of
extremists Maduro refuses to acknowledge
the dozens of countries that recognize
opposition leader Juan wydo his
country's severe economic crisis nor its
desperate need of humanitarian aid his
government is blocking aid shipments
that the u.s. government is massing in
Colombia across a barricaded bridge from
Venezuela
primero control the United States
government has set up with the
compliance of the Colombian government
in order to humiliate the Venezuelans
Minister hombres anis whele is a country
that has the capacity to satisfy all the
needs of its people the administration
has sanctioned Venezuela's primary
revenue source its state-owned oil
company is trying to divert funds from
Maduro to interim president Juan Guido
[Applause]
and build international pressure to
compel Maduro to yield power we're very
optimistic the community of nations will
rally support away from Maduro and
towards the Venezuela people China and
Russia have invested billions in
Venezuela and have supported maderos
government yet China is now in
discussions with the opposition trying
to secure its investments according to
The Wall Street Journal
Maduro still appears to have the support
of venezuela x' military leadership and
he says he has their loyalty though
american officials say Maduro has paid
for that loyalty through corruption
brett richardson at the State Department
rich Thanks